you ever fired something so nasty you
just start blaming an imaginary person
did you oh did you do that that smells
ungodly no I don't do that I'm a
Christian I believe in the Lord Oh what
is going on YouTube
YouTube and what's up you like the setup
I did it just for you watch this much
you like it movies very much that's
right ladies hold on to your vagina
hurts cuz I got lice and that beautiful
HD look at me yeah please don't
unsubscribe I'm good now recently my
friend introduced me to a game called
flappy birds that no and before we even
go start this off and I'll tell you
something I'm not in the games games
really not a thing in fact if you look
at my iPad I have nothing but
productivity apps and porn popcorn
popcorn because you eat it oh yeah
but let me tell you something about that
game oh that's right hey [ __ ] game I
never tell you the reasons why so you
don't know what it is
LG out baby let's go hey we came into
this one I like it Oh like I said I'm
not a gamer but in my years of playing a
lot of random games I have yet to need a
game that has pissed me off
then comes this game flappy birds and it
does piss me off
matter of fact you changing into Angry
Birds because that's what you do what
your [ __ ] names so um can do it now
do it now first off let me ask you this
why you got to make the game so goddamn
hard you know what this game does it
[ __ ] with your emotions and makes you
feel like a piece of [ __ ] and you want
to know why because the game is so
simple that eventually you should get
good at it but it does not happen what
you find out what this game is there's
really no gray area you either really
good in it or yeah suck [ __ ] balls
and I have sucked a lot of balls in the
past few days on waiting now I
understand that for kids this game may
be fun because on a child's intellectual
level it just matches up problem is I'm
gonna dull and it took me two hours to
get job boys don't laugh you know what
the worst part is when you're minding
your own damn business
and this is little kid nephew and he
gets a higher score than you [ __ ] that
bull true story I was chilling at a
restaurant and there was little kids
playing flappy birds and he said mummy
I got an 87 huh I'm gonna take some
mouse you know what I did I put that
little [ __ ] in this place I locked it
behind them and I whispered [ __ ] I will
beat your tiny little ass ain't nobody
love you that's right little boy you old
nothing know the consequences of your
actions show off for those of you who
don't know what this game is this gang
is about this little bird when you tap
on the screen it'll fly and so you don't
make it bump into these little green
pipes that's it oh you gonna judge me
acting like this game is all easier [ __ ]
you don't know until you actually play
that [ __ ] screen is sensitive and
he'll chop your face off jump into a
garbage can and like stuff on fire I
just don't get it [ __ ] bird flap the
belt attached the screen he should died
the pipe but damn special to his face
the simplicity of the game and not being
able to progress forward after hours and
hours of playing is what pisses you off
because it makes you look stupid huh
what's my high school you ask you take
the one and you divided by none of your
[ __ ] business and now some of
you out there posted scores like you got
200 something ain't nobody get above a
200 on that damn game if you did that's
witchcraft and sorcery you devil you
gonna help I said it could Devin cut
with a condom make condoms condemnation
if you really did get over 200 points on
your score will guess what you must have
forgot to feed your kids and go to work
and pay your bills you [ __ ] lowlife
scum for any of you out there that have
played this game this game emotionally
[ __ ] you up am i right it's funny
because just as angry as this game you
make you it makes you ten times happier
when you finally pass up your score it's
like seeing a tip for the first time in
real life in fact that feeling is so
good you could be in your room your girl
could be butt naked with a popsicle in
mouth do you wanna have sex you like no
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out you don't ruin my
score baby you ready oh my god I'm
flexible yeah huh what was it oh you
done [ __ ] a must
PACA [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out I'm done with
you you know what whatever you get J
bitching buddy gave you game for this
game maybe all these flappy is your
flappy ass titties flappy birds you know
what I hate when you bought the pass of
your score and some dumbass calls you
huh score right up so what you up to you
in resonate I'm going to kill you I need
another thing don't want somebody else I
pad and beat that flappy bird score some
[ __ ] got 22 on my bed you know I can't
get past the sticks
I'm your calm down about the pass out of
[ __ ] i'ma say my my my my Cooper and
your something there's some random
[ __ ] said to me just delete that
[ __ ] think it's that easy hot don't you
you don't know [ __ ] the problem is you
want to delete the game but the game is
not only a store anymore so if you
delete it it's gone forever it's rare
you want flappy bird is flappy bird is
the ring from Lord of the Rings you know
that [ __ ] is evil but you can't throw
it in the [ __ ] lava because it wants
it precious y'all remember that movie
when Frodo told samurais to go home Sam
go home what mr. Frodo
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he walked 6,000 miles and
he told him to go home like it was a
walk across the street of [ __ ]
Sam go home go home [ __ ] we're inside a
volcano
the hell is this
I picked on out of nowhere that's right
you were upgraded to bed my iPad I'll
practice shitty if it ain't broke don't
fix it and in fact if you look at my
iPad is riddled with nothing but my mom
I hate that [ __ ] game and I'm a
little taken in and I'm gonna tell you
the reasons why so y'all going to know
what it is but what you got baby let's
get it Oh God you think it's easy don't
you know you stupid as hell that
sentence up in the head
what's my eyes huh huh butt naked with a
possibility mouth ha ha ha
gotta get deep
[Music]